>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Maria A. Palante: For those
of you just joining us we had an
incredibly stimulating morning
this morning and a
wonderful keynote,
and this afternoon we're going
to begin to hear from creators
and before I say
that I just want
to also again thank the
Center for the Protection
of Intellectual Property.
And over here you'll see very
intelligent energetic looking
students, and I think,
if you don't mind I think
they're our future and I'd
like to recognize them for
helping us to put this on today.
[ Applause ]
I also want to make a
point to thank John Conyers
who is the Ranking Member of
the House Judiciary Committee.
When I testified before
the committee in favor
of comprehensive
review of copyright law,
the Copyright Office
made the point that no
such review would be complete
without looking at moral rights.
And John Conyers who, has been
a lifelong advocate of authors
and artists, asked us formally
to commence such a study.
So as we said this morning,
this symposia cosponsored
with George Mason Law
School is the beginning
of that public dialogue.
And with that I'd like to
turn it over to Kim Isbell
who is Senior Counsel in
our Department of Policy
and International Affairs.
>> Kim Isbell: Thanks Maria.
You know, as Maria just
alluded to one of the key things
about this panel that I think is
really interesting is it's the
first opportunity to really hear
from the artists themselves.
You know this morning, we heard
from a lot of lawyers talking
about what moral rights
the United States does
or doesn't recognize, how
you could assert more rights
under various provisions
of U.S. law
and then the very
interesting keynote
by Professor Ginsberg
talking about what she views
as a very important moral
right, the right of attribution
and how we could go
about codifying it.
But this panel is
really focused on:
what do artists themselves
think?
How do moral rights impact
their day to day work?
How do they impact them both
professionally and personally?
Which moral rights
do they care about?
Which moral rights make their
lives easier or more difficult?
And so for that reason,
I'm going to take a slightly
different approach to this panel
than we have in the
prior panels.
I'm not going to start off
asking our panelists a bunch
of questions.
Instead I want to give each
of them about five minutes
to really talk to you
from their own perspective
as to what moral rights and
what this symposium mean to them
and what they think
should be the key takeaways
as the Copyright Office is
going into a larger study
of the issue of moral rights.
Before I do that though
I am just quickly going
to introduce our panel,
and then I'm going
to turn the microphone
over to Melvin.
Our first speaker
is Melvin Gibbs.
He's a musician,
bassist, composer,
general musician,
Renaissance man.
He's also the president of the
Content Creators Coalition,
who is really out there
advocating for artists
in the area of copyright
and in other areas.
And so we are very
glad he could come
down from New York to join us.
Next to him is David Lowery.
He's a songwriter.
He's a recording artist.
You've probably heard
of some of his bands.
He was in Cracker and
Camper Van Beethoven,
and he also helped found
Pitch-A-Tent Records.
He's been a frequent speaker
for artists rights in many
of these discussions that
most of us participate in.
He's a very strong advocate
for the rights of composers
and the rights of recording
artists in the United States.
Next to him is Yoko
Miyashita [laughter].
Sorry I apologize.
She's Senior Vice President and
General Counsel at Getty Images.
She came to us all the way
from Seattle to join us today,
so we are very glad
she could be here.
Next to her is Professor
Sean O'Connor.
He is the Boeing International
Professor at the University
of Washington Law School.
We actually have a number of
Seattleites on the panel today.
And he's done extensive
research in the area
of moral rights and copyright.
And finally last, but definitely
not least, is Scott Turow.
He is an attorney and an author.
He's written nine
best-selling books
and has also been very
active in these issues
and so I personally am really
looking forward to hearing
from all our panelists.
And so with that I'm going
to turn it over to Melvin.
>> Melvin Gibbs: Good afternoon.
Howdy [laughter].
I was about to use
Kimberly but is it more --
, should I be saying Ms.
IsBell in this context?
>> Kimberely: Kimberly is fine.
[launghter]
>> Melvin: All right so
I'm going to say Kimberly
so you know I'm trying to
get with the protocol here.
Anyway as Kimberly said
earlier there was a lot of talk
about the law and
intricacies of the law.
I'm a musician.
We think about the law as part
of a more holistic way
we think about the world.
For me personally, in addition
to thinking about the law
when I have to think
about it I think
about what my music
means philosophically
and what it means economically.
And once I start thinking
about music, you know you have
to start thinking about
how you translate it,
and then it becomes a question
of thinking about metaphors.
And as musicians we're basically
stuck in two metaphors.
We are stuck in a metaphor
where we are workers;
we are making a musical work.
Or we are employees
creating a product.
For me, neither one of
those things actually works.
I actually think of myself
as part of a community
and creating for a community.
And in the context of this
society, the goal seems
to be dissemination of
creativity, getting it out to
as many people as possible.
And the question becomes,
for somebody like me
who is creative, is how am I
going to make that process work.
Leaving aside the kind
of inherent you know
heteronormative male aspect
of the word dissemination you
have the question of [laughter],
you have the question
of what does that mean?
Dissemination is a process
that starts from an individual
to another individual.
So inherently for the
dissemination process to work,
the individual has
to be recognized.
So how that works in the context
of a community is very simple.
You know who the guy down
the street is who does X,
Y or Z. For us as musicians,
there might be a guy--
for me there was literally
the man who lived next door
who started me off on music.
The question becomes I needed
to know who this person was.
In the context of a community,
of course you're going
to know that, but in
the context of 2016
when we have aggregated groups
of data it becomes difficult
to impossible to know who these
individuals are unless there is
some mechanism specifically
built to make that happen.
So looking at the idea of
moral rights in the context
of this society today I would
say to have this balance
between community and individual
is actually more important
than ever.
To have a really large
scale dissemination
of creativity the individual
creators have to be recognized.
Alright? Somebody asked
why is the law necessary
in the earlier panel.
To answer that I'll
give an experience.
I've been consulting at a
startup for the past few months,
almost a year now, and one
of the things I've learned is
that nothing gets built
at a startup unless it
is absolutely necessary
for it to exist.
And the reasons that
it's necessary
to exist are basically only two.
It has to be a business
reason or it has
to be a legal or
regulatory reason.
It will not get built
because I want it to.
There has to be some
affirmative reason
that the tech community
has to do this.
So that's my short
answer to that.
For us attribution
that is our currency.
I don't exist if people don't
know who I am and I mean
that in the most literal
sense of I don't eat.
So every time something goes
out that I've participated
in that I don't get attribution
for it affects my family.
And how that affects
the community is
that the less I am able to
create the less I'm able
to help other people create.
And the less the community of --
, it shrinks the
community of artists
which will eventually
shrink the creativity
of this country as a whole.
I don't have a watch on, I
don't know how I'm going here.
Kimberely:
>> One more minute.
>> Melvin: Okay.
There is a bit of an
overlap between economic use
and moral use, which I
guess we'll get into later.
But I can speak as somebody
who was mentored by a lot
of the older jazz
musicians in New York City
that you cannot really
separate them.
There are a lot of
things that --
, attribution and
integrity are both important.
And for us as musicians, it's
a slightly different issue
because we are performers.
It's not like in a book
where you have one
version of the book.
We play a song today, we'll
play it again tomorrow.
Each performance is unique
and each performance can
be disseminated on its own.
So I think there's
a different --
, there's room for a different
way of thinking about this idea
that integrity will
somehow hinder the process
of remix culture.
I think that this is
something we'll examine further
but I just wanted to
touch on that right now.
>> Kimberely: Okay,
thank you Melvin.
David Lowery.
>> David Lowery:
Thank you Melvin.
You know about 23 years
ago I had a song released,
and it started to
become popular on radio.
One day I get a call from
the senior vice president
of promotions at the record
label, and he basically says
"that song, you know that song's
not about being stoned, right?"
[laughter] And I'm
like, "of course it's
about being stoned Michael,"
but he kept saying it to me
and then finally I was like,
"oh is there a problem?"
He goes "yeah, I got this letter
I want you to sign and I need
to fax it to a few
radio stations."
So despite the fact
that I signed a letter
that said the song "Low,"
which has a chorus "hey, hey,
hey like being stoned"
[laughter] is
about being stoned.
Despite the fact that I
essentially signed a letter
that said that it didn't, it is.
And I guess in the world
of alternative rock
and rock radio songs about
being stoned there are a couple
of other people who have a few
tracks that basically come out
and say that and one of
them of course is Tom Petty.
So about the time that
we were first dealing
with digital distribution-- at
first involuntarily by the likes
of Napster and Kazaa and
Grokster and things like that--
somebody, probably because they
were stoned, mislabeled my song
"Low" as being a Tom Petty song
called "Like Being Stoned .MP3"
or "Tom Petty - Low -
106" I guess 108 must
have been an MP3 disc
that they ripped it from.
And for the next six or seven
years I had this ongoing battle
to kind of correct
this misrepresentation
that that was actually a Tom
Petty song to the point where --
, what's the name
of this website?
And it's still out there.
If you look it up on LastFM
it says it's a Tom Petty song.
Picture of Tom Petty there.
There's a Wikia called
misattributed
and the Wikia misattributed song
that's one of the first examples
of a song being misattributed
to artists.
So you've got to
think about this.
So my point, and I think
there's a lot of people here
that feel the same way,
is that attribution,
you can't really
separate attribution
from the economic rights.
I mean it's the same thing.
Now we can decide what we
are going to do about that,
because the last thing I want is
a DMCA loophole that can drive
like a truck or several
thousand trucks through.
But it is definitely -- , to
look at attribution as separate
from an economic right is
ridiculous, because A) one,
you know all those people are
freely downloading those songs,
well maybe, maybe they would
have come to the concert,
but they would have gone to a
Tom Petty concert [laughter].
Also the fact is is when you're
a performer you know you build
up a certain brand name on the
basis of your previous album
so even before your album comes
out it gets a value,
and economic value.
Because it's going to be
based on the popularity
of the songs before that more
people are going to listen
to it, maybe buy it,
get licensed in films.
I mean it's really, it's silly
that it's not an economic right
or that we would even think
that it's not an economic right.
I guess the other thing is
that, I find there's a lot of --
, you have this problem built
into our system for songwriters.
Like my example is
a funny example
as a performer, you know this.
But when you look at songwriters
they are almost never attributed
in the digital world.
I mean I guess you
could dig around.
I was using a popular
streaming service
and they do have a lyrics
plug-in that you can load
into the program
and then you click
on lyrics for one of my songs.
It was being performed
by another band
but this was the song I wrote
and I looked at the lyrics
and stuff and I was like
that's great, there's lyrics
and that's attributed to the
wrong people as a writer.
So I guess that's my point.
It's an economic
issue, very strongly.
>> Kimberely: Okay, thank you.
Now to go to Yoko
to give us sort
of the business perspective
on this.
>> Yoko Miyashita:
You know it's great
to follow Melvin and David.
Thank you for that context
because it definitely touches
on a number of things that
we see in my industry.
So just a little
background on Getty Images.
We represent close to 200,000
individual photographers as well
as having a staff of
150 staff photographers.
So we are both stewards
and distributors
of third-party content as
well as owners and generators
of our own content.I
was thinking about this
as you were talking about these
issues, and I've been with Getty
for about 11 years and I would
split those years as sort
of pre-viral, pre-social
to the current state.
And I would look at sort of
our activities particularly
on the enforcement side as
seeing instances of uses
and policing them, and
realizing with online platforms
with the DMCA loopholes
that that just simply
became untenable.
So Getty took -- , really looked
at this as a business issue
because when the genie
is out of the bottle
on social media it's out.
There is no stuffing it back in.
And the big issue we encounter
here, particularly on images,
is what I call the
right-click-copy-upload
paradigm.
When that happens, the metadata
that we have hired people
to apply all of the
author's information,
the copyright information,
all of those attributes
that would ordinarily travel
with an image get stripped.
So what happens?
That image gets orphaned.
That information
you would have had
about that author not only
has that been infringed,
not only has your economic
right there been messed with,
it's now been disconnected
from the key information
that tells you who
actually created that image,
who is the author behind that.
So it's an issue
that we have looked
at from a business
perspective and said,
"all right this is happening."
You can send all the
takedown notices in the world,
and you will never
solve this issue.
So what have we done as a
company is really looked at ways
of distributing content to
actually bring attribution back.
How do you leverage this innate
human need to share images?
Well you do that
by offering embed.
In May 2014, we launched an
offering through our website
for free embed use for
noncommercial purposes.
We hai spent years pursuing
these small nonprofit
organization school
projects and really
that is a terrible PR campaign.
Really whacking the
schoolteachers over the head
with a C&D and a
lawsuit or demand
for payment really not great for
company PR, not great for us.
So what did we say?
We opened up 90 plus
percent of our collections,
and said if you want
to use our content
for noncommercial use great.
Here's our embed and
what does it too?
It includes a small watermark
as well as attribution.
Give the creators credit
for what they've done.
And it also links
back to our site,
so if someone actually likes
that picture they can go
through then, make their way
back to the Getty Images site,
explore more images by a
particular photographer.
Soon after embed we've
launched social sharing.
So if you now go to the
Getty Images website
and see a picture you like
we encourage you to share it
but it will be shared
with attribution,
a link back wherever
those platforms allow us.
So you do again --
, can correlate that back to
the person who created it.
I'm not saying this
is the ideal solution
but this is the solution that
we currently have in the context
of where the legal
framework stands.
If it's going to be shared
we want it to be shared
with attribution, with a
possible potential for people
to find more images
from these creators.
The other, you know the
other thing that one
of our affiliates, Getty Images
acquired a technology in 2011.
It was the frontrunner in
image recognition software.
They do digital fingerprinting
and essentially help you
identify images on the internet.
You can see the obvious
use cases
for pursuing infringements.
But what we've done is
really collected one
of the largest indices
of online imagery.
So a fantastic solution
for orphan works,
but also just an open API.
So the technology is out
there to help platforms,
to help companies, to help
anyone who is looking figure
out who actually
created an image,
who actually owns the copyright,
where it's available
for licensing.
This technology exists.
It's out there.
We offer it.
But there needs to be an impetus
to drive uptake of these kinds
of available technologies.
We know they exist.
They are underutilized across
the industry but again,
that is a process to
reattach this attribution,
to reattach the metadata,
to reattach all
of these key attributes
that go directly
into the economic
viability of creative works.
I wanted to touch on a point you
made, David, about to have --
, it's not just knowing who the
author is so you can search.
This is all driven in the
platform space by algorithms.
If your name is not
showing up with that song
and is not being
attributed to you,
everything else that's
driving the algorithms
that will drive traffic
back to you or discovery
of your content, those
connections are being cut off.
So I do see these as
absolutely interrelated
and you cannot separate the two.
I think that's really it for me.
Thank you.
>> Sean O'Connor: Thanks,
okay, I'm actually going
to use a timer because I'll
just ramble on too long.
First I want to clarify
that I'm not really a moral
rights expert.
I know that's shocking and I
probably shouldn't be up here.
I always joke that I'm a jack
of all trades, master of none.
I was a singer/songwriter
for a long time but not
as good as these gentlemen.
I recorded some stuff, did get
some airplay, but I was one
of those guys was better as a
bar band performer and would go
to the studio, and
it was pretty good
in the studio the stuff I
wrote but not good enough
to quite get me there.
So after that I went and
got a masters in philosophy.
I was a bartender, parked cars,
you know did every stupid
job you could imagine
and then ultimately ended up in
law school for various reasons.
And through the magic of
academic tenure I've held a job
for like 13 years now which
is really quite good for me.
But -- , thank you, I know,
my parents are still shocked
that that's happening.
But, so, I think the only
reason I'm here is kind
of perhaps a synthesizer,
looking at both the creator side
because I have experience-- that
I know what it takes not only
to write songs but also to
get them into the studio.
Again I wasn't good at it
but I understood the
production process.
What I liked about what Melvin
was saying was distinguishing
between musicians in
their performance capacity
and in their recording capacity.
And so I think with moral
rights, and what I just want
to address for a
couple of minutes here,
is that the key thing is when
we're focused on musicians
and other creators when they are
creating what I call artifacts,
a particular finished
work, a recorded song,
a book that's going
to be published,
an artwork that's
going to be released.
And then the key is-- and it's
related to a project I'm working
on right now funded
by CPIP actuall--
looking at arguing
that copyright should perhaps be
viewed is as much an incentive
for publication for
making a public commitment
to that particular
vision of a creative work,
as it is an incentive
for creativity
and the other things
we normally say.
Why? Well because if you
talk to a bunch of creators,
and now Melvin and David will
correct me quickly on this,
but I don't think, you
guys don't write songs just
because there's copyright,
you don't create --
, well maybe you
do, I don't know.
So in other words if you say
oh my gosh I am not going
to become a songwriter if
there were not copyright?
>> David: Yeah but I don't think
you do album eight or nine.
>> Sean: True, right [laughter],
so there's a role
for it, exactly.
And then the question becomes
how do you get it all financed?
But the point here
is that I think a lot
of people now realize that is
copyright as only an incentive
to create probably doesn't
tell the whole story.
It's a big part of the story
but it's not the complete story.
And so if you look
at the history
of the term publication
going back to Roman period
"publicari," it was
making a public commitment.
And so what I think has
become invisible to us
in the social media age
where people blur the line
between public and private.
We tweet everything out.
We Instagram everything out.
Snapchat everything out.
But think about if you are
a creator, and this is true
for a creative artists and
even for us wonky academics,
when you finally say, and I'm
looking at the journal students
over there, okay you guys, and
I have stuff I've published
with them, they always
send me, "is it final?
Are you going to
give us the sign off?
Can we release, can
we publish this now?"
That's a fraught moment
because if I say something wrong
in there, I didn't catch a
typo, it comes back to haunt me.
And so now on the performance
side, on the improv side,
sometimes the rough edges around
it can be exactly what you want.
But in the finished artifact
side it's often not what
you want.
You're trying to get a
very particular thing.
So what does this
mean for moral rights?
Well, first moral rights is
important because we angst a lot
about is it good
enough to be published,
to be publicly released?
And second, without
getting too maudlin,
but in the world we live
in today you have a lot
of potential risk and liability
for things you publicly put
out there as creators.
We don't have to give specific
examples, but just think
about that in the world today.
And so the notion of integrity.
What if somebody takes
my carefully constructed
"here's what I really
meant to put out there"
and they change it and
my name is still on it?
And now suddenly that could get
me just professional problems,
or it could get me physical
harm kind of problems.
Can't I then get my
name taken off it?
Or can't I just withdraw
the work entirely
if I realize that's
not what I want
to publicly commit to anymore?
Okay, so that's my main point.
Second point is that I think,
and I like that Professor
Ginsberg was starting to open
up that door and talk
about work-made-for-hire,
because that's going
to be I think one
of the biggest problems
for meshing in or bringing
in a full moral right system
into the U.S. copyright system.
Our work made for hire is
based on the economic basis
of our copyright system,
so it means the economic
employer can be the author
for purposes of copyright
statute.
But there's another sense
of work-made-for-hire
where you have -- ,
and this goes back
to actually continental
precedents going back
into the Renaissance period
where you have the great artiste
who directs people
and usually then his,
but it could be her studio,
and they actually implement.
They execute on things.
So you know we know the
case is about how you decide
who is an author and who
is not but that's going
to become I think incredibly
important as you think
about then bringing in a
fuller moral right system
if that's something
you want to do.
With that I'll turn
it over to Scott.
>> Scott Turow: Great.
Well thank you all.
My acquaintance with moral
rights began what is now a long
time ago when I was thrilled to
get a draft of a movie contract
for the rights to "Presumed
Innocent" and my life had gone
through an extraordinary
transformation.
I had written "Presumed
Innocent"
on the morning commuter train
and finished it in my basement
and all of a sudden, literally,
I was that proverbial person
in the creative world who
gets struck by lightning.
And in the process
the movie rights
to the book were purchased.
A draft contract arrives
and of course it says
that among the rights I
am selling are my right
to make a claim based
on droit morale,
and I'm sure people are
fainting all over the room
of my French accent
[laughter], or moral rights.
So I called my lawyer
and I said,
"well what are moral rights?"
And he said, "well it
has got nothing to do
with you, you're an American."
[ Laughter ]
But I've always been
conscious of the concept just
because I've been
through law school.
I never took a copyright
class, but the notion just
because of the term
appeal to me.
And there is -- , we recognize
creative work as standing
on some kind of different
platform than other products
in the marketplace,
because of the intimacy
of the creative act.
And for lack of any other term,
artists traditionally
are believed
to have put a little
bit of their soul
into whatever they create,
whether it's what they paint
or the songs they compose,
the sculptures they make
or for artists and authors the
productions that come from them.
And I think we do have the right
to assert that there is a kind
of specialness in creative
work and that is recognized
in terms of moral rights.
Everybody here has
talked generally
about the right of attribution.
I sit here on what is a sad
day for the Authors Guild
of which I was once president.
Our long-running
fight with Google
over the Google Books project
is officially over today.
The Supreme Court refused
to grant cert in the case.
And I doubt there are
any people in the room
who need a long-winded
explanation of what was involved
in the Google Books case.
And it's certainly true
that our opposition was
fundamentally economic.
The notion that a large
corporate entity could decide
on its own to take and
copy an authors work,
not change a single word of
it, offer no new expression
and still make the
entire work available
through selective display
of so-called snippets
seemed fundamentally wrong.
But we've lost that fight.
But the moral rights issues
still remain in that discussion.
And just by way of example,
at one point we had reached
a settlement with Google
which was one of
those situations
where the Justice
Department came in
and disagreed with both sides.
And I still, of course, disagree
with the Justice
Department about this.
But we found in our own
membership substantial
opposition to the settlement.
Not overriding, and what
were they objecting to?
They believed, they didn't like
the idea of Google coming in
and just taking their work.
They didn't want it
displayed on Google.
And even though we
argued that the settlement
in fact would give them
the right to opt out
and withdraw their work,
they found it fundamentally
offensive.
Now songwriters don't
exist in that world.
They have a compulsory
licensing system.
Other people of course,
objected to Google books
because of the right
of integrity.
They didn't like the idea
that there was this robot
being created that would deal
with their books selectively
and choose snippets
based on certain words.
And certainly the right
to control publication
of your work is implicated
in this kind
of wholesale use and display.
Rights of attribution of course
are important to authors too.
It's rare to steal
an entire novel
and have somebody put
his or her name on it.
But poets and essayists are in
this world of rampant plagiarism
of course, often
exposed to that.
But all of these
concepts seem to me
to remain very much
relevant to the discussion
of the author's place
in the world, too.
>>Kimberley: Okay, thank you.
So I think I'm hearing a couple
of different themes
throughout this panel.
One is that it's very hard
to separate the concept
of moral rights from the
concept of economic rights,
especially in situations where
your reputation has a lot to do
with the economic value
of what you're producing.
And I'm also hearing that
there seems to be a lot
of consensus here
that attribution is a
relatively important moral right
for creators and for authors.
But what I thought
was interesting
and we first started getting
into with Sean's discussion,
is sort of the more
reputational and other sort
of personal importance
of moral rights.
And so I would like to hear
a little bit more from some
of the panelists, if
they'd like to speak on it,
about putting aside economic
rights-- not that you can,
you have to eat obviously
economic rights are important--
but how do things like, for
example Tom Petty being listed
as the author of your
song, sort of impact you
on a more reputational
or personal level?
Anyone want to take that on?
>> David: Well I'll say
that a lot of people thought
that we were playing
a cover after that,
which lowered our sort of
status in some weird way.
So I mean that was
one of the things.
But a lot of people object
to the uses of their songs
in certain kinds of commercials
and things like that,
and I know this is like
rights of publicity
and they crossed
into other realms.
I'm pretty relaxed
about all of that.
I mean if the San Francisco
Giants started using one
of my songs I'd have
a problem with that.
[laughter] -
>> Kimberely: What
about politicians?
>> David: Well generally if
they stay away from homophobia,
racism, certain key
things, I actually,
we have very diverse political
views in both of our bands
so we kind of let more use of
that happened than most bands.
Am I being neutral enough?
>> Kimberley: Very
middle of the road -
>> David: Yes, so but that's an
issue -- , I don't know maybe -
>> Melvin: Well I mean
I think it's an odd-
>> David: I'm a collective
for musicians so -
>> Melvin: I'm more speaking for
friends of mine, I mean as far
as going back to thinking,
I hate to bring it back
to attribution even
though you're trying
to take it somewhere else.
[laughter] But a
bunch of friends
of mine have been
sampled multiple times,
and it would be very
nice for people to know
that they are the actual people
that are playing on that record,
on the original songs.
It would be nice for people
to know who the people
who did the original songs were
in a more comprehensive
way simply because,
thinking particularly of a
friend of mine who played
on an Edwin Birdsong song
that Daft Punk sample,
those guys are all still around.
They could have just as
easily hired those guys
to come play the song again
and it would've been
better for everybody.
So it bleeds into the whole
"what is creative
and what isn't."
Because to me in 2016 a lot of
these things that people default
to as creativity
tactics, they default
to because a certain
legal mechanism was set
up that drove things down a road
that was the road that it went
down because that was the
one that was the clear one.
I think if some other
paths are cleared up,
we'll see different
kinds of creativity
and we'll see different
kinds of income generation.
As far as effect on
reputation, yes it's interesting
because now I'm thinking
of some other people I know
who actually are in
a position to be able
to control their catalogs.
And they've been pretty
adamant about policing use
and making sure that
people, hip-hop songs
that they don't approve of,
their music doesn't get on them.
And I can also think
of quite a few people
as David alluded it goes into --
, it starts to bleed into right
of publicity, but I know
many people who have refused
to let their songs be used
in commercials for example.
And I know that that's an issue
now for quite a few friends
of mine because of YouTube
and because of the fact
that now they spent their whole
career saying no to commercials,
and now whenever a commercial
pops up they have no control
over it, which is off-topic
to this conversation.
But it's the basic idea
of yes you do spend --
, if your career was built on
"okay you have a certain level
of integrity" and
now everybody--
that's being assaulted--
then your reason,
the reason that people respected
you as an artist starts
to go away and it makes you
less valuable to your people
and less valuable to yourself.
>> Sean: So I would add-- and
again maybe I'm just off base
because again I'm not as
talented as these guys
so my perspective, it might
be why I never became a famous
musician-- but so first, one as
a small side note about knowing
where the samples
come from and just
to plug hometown radio stations
KEXP did a deconstruction
of Paul's Boutique
where they went through,
they took an entire programming
day and went through the songs
and pulled out and played
the original entire song
that was sampled and
then gave the credit,
maybe not to every musician on
the array, but they got as close
as you could get so that's
incredibly important.
That was cool to happen.
What I think I was trying to
get at though with this kind
of final release of the
artifact and not is a lot
of what I think you
both are talking
about with integrity is
thinking about using your song
for political reasons,
things like that,
but what I'm really
trying to get at is,
you're still I think perhaps
thinking about the final release
that you authorize and then
what happens with it after that.
So let me give a
hypothetical: You've signed
over all your rights to a label,
not to make the label
the bad guy or anything
but you've signed over -- , no,
no really I'm really not trying
to do that I'm just saying
for the hypothetical--
you gave all your rights away.
You had a bunch of
stuff that you're
in the studio wasn't quite up to
par that you would have released
and now they say the contract,
you're doing something else,
and they say okay "we're going
to release from the archives,"
and it's a bunch of
stuff you're like,
"I never would have
released that," so that's
in some ways what
I'm trying to get at.
What you think about that?
>> Melvin: Well I mean just
on the never released I mean I
was known for back in the day
for being the guy who
would derail a contract
over those kinds of things
so for me I mean I think
in my whole career I've
definitely done less
than five works for hire and I
think it's two or three maximum.
I just don't do it,
that's me personally.
But it's interesting because
I kind of wanted to leave
that alone but since
we're coming back
to it it's the copyright
versus moral rights thing.
Copyright is for everybody else
but moral rights is for us.
When I make something it's
mine until you know about it.
>> Sean: We would hope.
>> Melvin: From the standpoint
of an artist it is a piece of --
, it's literally a
piece of property,
I mean it becomes virtual
property once it's printed
but when I'm thinking
about it it's mine.
So it's kind of two
different conversations.
I mean to me when we're talking
about copyright were talking
about okay what happens
when everybody else
starts to know about it.
But the real basic thing
that is called moral rights,
to me that's -- , we get,
that's kind of intrinsic
and we make an agreement
with the rest of you all
that we are going to
give some of those
up so you all can hear it.
But at the end of the day,
we try to figure out ways
to put it back in the
contract, some guys like me
who just won't do work-for-hire.
Everybody's not as
militant about it as I am
and that's one reason I don't
work in LA, blah blah blah.
[laughter] I don't so.
But-- it's something,
it definitely impacts the
creativity of this country.
I've just got to
leave it at that.
>> Sean: So one last thing
to close the loop on that.
So that for me is
Statute of Anne
and our earlier copyright act
where there was the stronger
public/private divide.
The idea was you
create something,
you can control it
completely until it is ready
to be released because,
thank you Melvin,
and perhaps David agrees too,
it's very personal and until
that thing is ready you do
not want it getting out there.
>> Kimberely: So I actually
have a question for Yoko.
Are these types of issues
ones that are important
to the photographers that
Getty Images works with?
Do you help them enforce rights
of attribution in addition to,
obviously, the initiatives that
Getty has come up with to try
to embed and provide for social
sharing, but are these types
of concerns like "I really don't
want my photograph appearing
on this type of website or
in this type of concept."?
>> Yoko: The integrity
issues are really interesting
particularly because we really
sit and broker the relationship
between the artists and
essentially the people licensing
or purchasing content.
And we handle it contractually,
as you would imagine,
but the stock photography
industry is built
on "somebody takes your
picture and customizes it
and modifies it and
uses it in a way
that suits their particular
need" eliminating the need
to shoot custom content.
But what comes with that is
obviously these absolutely human
personal decisions and opinions
and thoughts about what is
and is not acceptable.
We're pretty clear about
those conversations
with our contributing
photographers
around you know we asked
you really aren't able
to exercise your moral rights
with respect to particular uses.
Yes, we have mechanisms
to say okay no use
in tobacco, no use in alcohol.
We have the ability and the
means to honor those types
of restrictions but
once you really put it
out into the distribution sort
of ecosystem there is
this understood exchange,
a contractual exchange around
what you can or can't control.
And notwithstanding sort of an
open dialogue and transparency
about that you just never know
what's really going to hit you
and what's quite personal.
And we've seen some really
interesting issues come up,
and we do have to deal with
those on a one-off basis and try
to find that middle ground.
And sometimes that means
that photographer
wants to pull content.
But if a campaign is
run, a campaign is run.
So you do see those
and we do sort of stand
in the middle again trying
to broker what is the best
solution for each side here.
And I think it's really --
, people are so creative you
just can never know what they're
going to come out with, and
it may be absolutely offensive
to some, it may not be.
I mean it is sort of what
makes it interesting.
But again to that
private/public, we just sort
of wait in the middle
and see what happens.
But what I'll go back
to is really I do think
technology has solutions
to offer in the space that have
yet to be really fully explored.
And when we talk about
control and when I think
about online it really
truly is the reflection
of those control mechanisms
within the 1s and 0s.
So I'm not sure that
answers that question, Kim.
>> Kimberley: So does anyone
else on the panel have thoughts
about sort of ways to manage
these issues about solutions,
or is it just a problem that
is inherent in the nature
of internet distribution?
>> David: Well I mean I feel
like sometimes we frame
the whole question wrong.
Like we are sort of worrying
about the rights of like a group
of consumers or an industry
or a preferred technology.
But rights only vest
in the individual.
And I don't think me asserting
my rights if it breaks
or wrecks a certain technology,
then it wasn't a good enough
technology in the first place
and it should die [laughter].
I mean think about what we lose?
How did we get this turned
around so backwards that we have
to pick winners and losers
in the technology world?
If the internet is the most
wonderful thing ever it should
be able to withstand me
asserting my moral rights.
Right?
>>Melvin: Well I mean the thing
I always say is that this idea
that information should be
free theoretically also applies
to your bank information.
But nobody has any problem
with having their bank
information locked down.
So it becomes a question
of what --
, going back to what I said
earlier what people want
to build and what
people need to build.
It's not theoretically
as Yoko said earlier,
I mean her pictures go
up with the metadata on
and then magically the
metadata disappears so the fact
that that happens is because
there was nothing built -
>> Yoko: We allowed
it to happen -
>> Melvin: To allow
it to remain.
Or you know I don't want
to put it the other way
but you know the
implication is there.
So I think as I said earlier
there are going to have
to be some affirmative
forcing of people's hands
to enforce community,
unfortunately.
Because people are just
going to build according
to what they can get
away with building.
>> Kimberely: So Scott
you've been kind of quiet.
Do you have any concluding
thoughts before we go
to audience questions?
>> Scott: Again I'm sitting
here thinking about all
of these issues as they apply
to authors, and of course,
you know our problems have
to do with theft, piracy,
which is I'm sure a
problem across the board.
And I'm also thinking
about the fact
that it would probably
behoove us, those who try
to be author's representatives
as well as authors,
to explain this in
the personal terms,
which I think moral
rights implicate
and the way Melvin's
been talking about it,
that you know yes it's property.
You're stealing property
but it's property plus.
Creative work always has been
and moral rights recognizes
that plus aspect
to creative work.
And I think it's important
because it's not
just being ripped off
by the pirate it's the personal
insult that goes with it.
Because look my books
are in the library.
People can go read them
for free, and I love that.
But that's because I chose
to participate in that system
and I didn't choose to
participate in a system
where somebody else is going
to take control of my work.
>> Kimberely: Okay so
we have about 10 minutes
for audience questions.
>> Audience: I have
a question for Scott.
How do you feel about
fan fiction?
>> Scott: You know I think it's
pretty interesting, personally,
and you know you can't
deal with this globally.
It depends on exactly
what is being done
and what exactly is being
appropriated and then what kind
of use gets made of it.
But what I like about the
moral rights discussion is
that it involves us
in discussing the spiritual
element of creative work.
I know when I write
something that it's going
to be meaningful, I hope, to an
audience and that they are going
to take it in and make use
of that imaginative
experience in their own way.
So fan fiction is
part of that process.
Again, it's complicated and it
becomes particularly complicated
if somebody is trying to make
economic use of something
that I want to control.
But you know the notion of it
it actually does appeal to me.
>> Melvin: I want
to just kind of tag
onto Scott's comments
a little bit.
I mean it seems people
have to remember
that we all started
off learning,
and we all started off
copying other people.
Creative people in general
are not against emulation.
We're not against remix.
We're not against any of that.
What we are against is this
distance that's been put
in between us and the
community of people
who would want to emulate us.
You know it's like the person
who told me how to play bass,
I learned, I was copying
him but then I was going
to his house every week.
The people that I was
listening to their records,
there was a relationship beyond
just okay there's a website
and the website is
scraping my data.
And I think that
to solve that is--
we kind of have to go backwards.
And that's why I think the moral
rights conversation is actually
applicable in this era.
>> Audience: Question
for David and Melvin,
as I'm sure you know Section 115
of the Copyright Act provides
for a compulsory license that
once you've written a song
that anyone else without
your permission can go ahead
and record a cover version.
Do you like that?
Does it bother you?
Do you think it bothers
most songwriters, composers?
>> Melvin: We are about to
go all Worldwide Wrestling
Federation with me
and [laughter].
It's two things that
don't go together.
I mean I am of two
minds over this.
I mean our organization
is pro-compulsory license.
The reason we are
pro-compulsory license--
but there is a very
strong caveat with that,
which is from our and the
issue is that there has
to be fair market
rate paid when a piece
of our creativity is used.
The reason I can support that is
because as I was saying earlier
we all start off learning
from other people.
And for me, balanced in the
context of American culture,
I hate to bring that
up, I hate to separate,
I feel that it allows
for creativity.
Having said that,
I 100% understand.
I'm 100% for autonomy.
And in a perfect universe,
I think that I would
probably go a different way,
but with the laws
that we have now
and the way this
country is structured,
our organization feels
that compulsory is
what we would support.
>> David: What was the
section of that act [laughter]?
I mean I feel pretty much
the same way Melvin does.
I mean I think people forget
though you can cover a song
in a venue and it's covered by
a blanket license and in theory
that whole process was--
until the DOJ stepped in--
it largely took place
in the private market.
I see that there
are other countries
that don't have compulsory
licenses,
but that have private market
solutions or free market more
or less solutions to trying
to license compulsories
for covers and stuff like that.
The problem with the
compulsory licenses is the
economic problem.
I think most people don't mind
having their songs covered.
So I'm against the
compulsory license
because it's essentially
a subsidy for --
, mostly because it
ends up being a subsidy
for winners the government
has picked in advance,
technology companies, even large
media companies previously.
So I would rather not have it.
>> Kimberely: Okay I
think this is going
to be our last question.
>> Jane Ginsburg: Thanks, I'd
like to ask you the question
that I was asked at the end of
my talk before lunch, which is,
you've spoken eloquently about
what moral rights mean for you
but how is that in
the public interest?
>> David: I don't know if --
, moral rights how is it
in the public interest?
>> Jane: So the question
that I was asked at the end
of my talk this is very nice
all the good things to say
about attribution rights but
what's in it for the public?
The implication of
the question being
that there is an opposition
between the interest
of the author in
being recognized
and the economic benefits that
might flow from that as well
as the psychological
benefits, but to the extent
that attribution rights
might make the dissemination
of the work more difficult
because you get bogged
down in trying to find
out who is the author
and identify the author so
we have less dissemination
of the work to the public.
What's the argument from
the author, as an author?
I gave the law professor
answer [laughter] -
>> [Name]: Okay,
pretty good answer.
>> Jane: What as authors can you
say about why recognizing you
as the creators of your
work, why is that good
for the public in general?
>> Can I take a quick
swipe at that one?
I believe that all of the rules
and laws we have are aimed
at stimulating creative
activity.
And if your work can be taken
without attribution, it,
to some, is going to be a
disincentive to doing it.
And again you know as
somebody who's privileged
to have wide readership,
and who doesn't pass a day
without getting fan mail, you
know I feel blessed by that,
by the relationship
that I've entered
into with all of those people.
And if you told me-- leaving
aside the incredible good
fortune financially
that I've also enjoyed--
that that could be
taken away from me
because attribution would
no longer be required,
that would be a huge loss.
It would change the meaning
of authorship and I'm sure
for many authors
and other creators
that it's a disincentive.
If you're saying that
there are certain mishaps
in the internet world
that we all know
about where attribution
gets lost that's one thing,
but if you're saying
that attribution
in general is no longer
going to be a right
that we value I truly believe
that you have diminished
the glory of authorship.
>> Sean: I'll take a slightly
different crack if I could
at that which is I agree
with that, but I also think
that what it gets you is it
gets you that public sphere,
that public discourse.
And that's what I was trying
to really hone in on today,
is that we had at
times in the past,
as Professor Ginsburg
knows, that with a lot
of scientific societies
going back
into the early scientific
revolution,
and yes copyright was important
on the science side not just
creative arts, it was a lot
of manuscript culture of things
being circulated privately
and partly because people
weren't ready to take that stand
and they needed some
other incentives to do it.
So what does moral rights
and attribution gets you?
Well it's what copyright
gets you as well.
It gets people putting
their stuff
out there publicly releasing
it not necessarily free
economically, but
putting it out there
so it could be a
robust public discourse.
>> Melvin: I would tag onto
that I mean going somewhere
that I wouldn't rarely
go in public,
going a little Darwinian.
I think that in attribution you
might actually have a situation
where the best people win.
I mean I talked to a
couple of friends of mine
who were professional
ghostwriters.
Nobody really wanted to share a
song so I'm just going to have
to riff one of my own on this
but ghostwriting is not a
new thing but who knows,
who knows if the person
who actually was painting
for Rembrandt maybe
that's the person
who should have been famous.
Because we don't have
attribution we'll never
really know.
I think, and in the context
of the music business,
the way the music business
is in 2016, I know that a lot
of people go uncredited
that are propping up a lot
of other people's careers and
I think that it would be better
for the people of
the world if some
of these talented people
actually got to get out from
under these other people and got
known for what they were doing.
It would make the
music world better.
It just would.
>> David: You mean change
a word, earn a third?
>> Kim: Okay, well I think
that's all the time we have.
Thank you so much to
all of our panelists.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.